[Applause]
excellent good evening welcome good to
see you guys
barrington how are you sir i'm fine good
to see you welcome to the f word what's
the secret success behind discovery bay
what is it basically the heart and the
passion and everybody loves working
there ernesto yeah jeff the secret
success behind santa maria what is it
argentina made it something special i
ripped the kitchen apart last night put
this grill especially for you
yes
it better be good yes yes don't set the
place on fire no no okay please now all
four of you yeah it's tonight yeah your
chance to show everybody how good you
are
let's get cooking tonight discovery bay
and santa maria del sur will be
competing in the f-word kitchen this is
how they got here
earlier this year i asked you to log on
to the f-word website and nominate your
favorite local restaurants
the response has been absolutely
phenomenal you told us about nearly 5
000 different places you love to eat
for tonight's america's heat you
nominated your favorite restaurants
serving food from north central and
south america
with such a huge range of cuisines from
across the atlantic my team and i really
had a work cut out
it's all freshly cooked and the meat is
of very high quality
from argentina to mexico from caribbean
to cuban we whittle down your uk
restaurant nominations looking for the
very best we're traveling across the
country really putting these nominated
restaurants under severe scrutiny and
after a month of searching it became
obvious that two of your nominations
stood out
i couldn't wait to put them to the test
first up santa maria del sur in
battersea
this hugely popular argentine steakhouse
is run by jose aldar and f word viewers
gave it rave reviews hello how are you
fine are you yeah good to see you
and now first name is jose jose good to
see you from argentina from argentina
the secret success behind the russian is
what
simplicity i think yeah just a proper
cooked argentine meat
with some nice wine from argentina also
here the people just you know they come
they ask for the steak they receive the
steak they enjoy it with wine and that's
it just steaks on the grill
and that grill is made by head chef
ernesto la brava would you prefer
cooking is it phillip ribei
filet ribeye and silva ernesto was
studying to be a lawyer but jacked in to
go to chef school in havana
it's quite different what is in my life
but yes i'm very happy to
be cooking argentina food in london
[Music]
santa maria del sur is famous in the
neighborhood for his delicious steaks
they opened in 2006 and have been
packing in customers ever since
the steak ordered it medium rare came
out beautifully cooked nice and
succulent in the middle you know great
sort of flavors on the outside
good quality meat is essential to the
success of santa maria so they insist on
importing only the very best steaks
i think the quality of the meat is
argentina is very good because the grass
is very good the wettest conditions are
fantastic the average time our steak is
hanging it's between 20 and 28 days so
the days of the meat is very nice
for my starter i try some traditional
argentine pasties empanadas
where are they made
here
everything homemade
the empanadas are start one chicken one
beef so savoury not too spicy most of
the customers are english yeah who can
pro proper size steak in the rest yeah a
russian is true to my own heart not a
vegetarian in sight anywhere
so far so delicious but next up is the
real test my rib eye straight from
ernesto's grill
lovely thank you wow
the steak's nice and thick honestly that
charcoal flavor is extraordinary pretty
good
and so nice to see it being done
properly
and then taking two seconds come over
guys
um so
thank you
um that was uh that was nice very nice
indeed um my issue is that the american
category is so diverse
because there's such a huge variety of
restaurants across the board
so my decision is
congratulations to you through the f
i mean word congratulations and that was
delicious really good and beautifully
cooked
seasoned beautifully cooked brilliantly
and more importantly flavour was
extraordinary
ernesto good luck
argentine
wine argentine beef and they they're
passionate about argentina look we're in
the middle of battersea they're amazing
i mean really good
i need to try to cook the most perfect
steaks for that moment i'm very very
happy so santa maria del surf are
through but who will be joining them
your other winning nomination in
america's category was an extraordinary
caribbean in huddersfield
[Music]
discovery bay is a tiny but intriguing
restaurant serving caribbean classics
like aki and saltfish and curried goats
it's owned by barrington douglas what
makes discovery beer successful is the
relaxed warming atmosphere the light
reggae and the soulful vibes in the
background you feel as if you're in the
caribbean and then when you stab your
fork into your meat and you taste it you
think you know what these people have
put heart soul and passion into
everything that we're doing i've been
here so many times i've practically
worked my way through the menu the
food is gorgeous
barrington has dedicated his entire life
to discovery bay he decided as a
teenager that he wanted to open a
restaurant and saved up for over 20
years he even remortgaged his house to
make his dream come true
at the age of 19
i said right every 100 pound i earn i'm
gonna put 20 pounds away
and the dream was to open a restaurant
and after 20 21 years i accumulated the
summer money and now i'm living my dream
barrington's clearly a man with
incredible commitment but is his modern
take on caribbean classics good enough
for the f word restaurant i sent f word
major dj b along to try it out
welcome to discovery thank you thank
the decor is 70s retro and there's
reggae on the stereo eating at discovery
bay is a very chilled affair
very laid back is the first time that
i've been escorted to a sofa to take my
my drink orders i found it very unusual
but very cool as well hello guys
is that you're right yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna be excited today your taste
buds are gonna go
barrington cooks classic jamaican dishes
inspired by his grandmother but with an
added british twist we got a vegetable
called callaloo but it's like an english
spinach so i'll do a caribbean spices
with english spinach
one of the best sellers on discovery
bay's menu is rum pork baron to cook one
up for jb
what is so special about this dish is
the sauce has been made with a bit of
rum you really give these flavors this
taste which is absolutely incredible hi
gordon jb filled me in
this was a tough category but discovery
babe passed jb's taste test with flying
colours hello discovery bay hi good
evening is that barrington yes speaking
yeah barrington gordon ramsay how are
you i'm fine fine very fine what does
your restaurant discovery bay do that
any other caribbean restaurant doesn't
do what discovery bear does we've got
heart
um everybody everybody everybody in here
has got passion well your customers are
certainly loyal the feedback has been
extraordinary you only have 36 seats in
your restaurant yes yeah you're gonna
have to focus on 50. congratulations
you're just through
the square dining room excellent thank
you very much thank you very much it
means a world to us all thank you very
very much
one happy barrington
we're in
we're in we're in
[Music]
i'm very excited you can tell when i'm
excited the cheeks go
they go right up
your nominations i've chosen two
extraordinary restaurants
will the f-word diners be charmed by
discovery bay's caribbean heart and soul
or will they prefer the delicious
simplicity of santa maria del sur
next on the menu the two restaurants
battle out for the america's title
but is one team celebrating too early
ernesto cynthia you can stop dancing now
maybe you can show me a few moves after
the main course yeah we're back in
london at the f-word restaurants
and tonight we're crossing the atlantic
and celebrating the amazing flavors of
north south and central america
after searching for months all over the
country we whittle down your nominations
to two fantastic restrooms
argentine grill house santa maria del
sur in south london and caribbean
restaurant discovery bay in huddersfield
[Music]
25 portions of each is not a race first
table santa maria hanover four girls
away table one four empanadas full
revive four peach yeah
thank you barrington on order four cups
table four four chicken caesar salad
four pork four peaches yes chef tonight
i've challenged both brigades to cook
their best chili and chicken starter
nice ernesto yeah love that smile you've
got when you're cooking yeah you're
always happy in the kitchen
outside you weren't very happy now in
the kitchen bang you light up
at santa maria del sur in south london
every night is party night and their
classic argentine food is a huge hit
with the locals you can hear it's quite
a quite lively place perfect place you
can come with you know just two of you
all come with a big party and have a
great experience either way
[Music]
santa maria are cooking chicken and
chili empanadas a classic argentinian
starter they fill the pastry cases with
chicken mixed with peppers onions eggs
tomatoes olives and mixed herbs
they pinch the cases shut and deep fry
until golden
they serve with a watercress fennel and
chilli salad and garnish with lemon
what's the secret behind a really good
empanada i think pastry good chicken
good flavor easy to made that's it right
barrington talk to me yes chef who
taught you to cook first who was this
there was all boys and um my mum was
before i was a bird so she pulled me to
one side and
showed me how to call can your mum think
that you are
and she had a special technique with a
wooden spoon what was that well at the
beginning my mum says um what you need
to do you need to watch the part and
every time i used to open my mouth and
say something excuse me i chose to say
it i didn't ask you to talk i asked you
to watch the part it worked
i think it worked it did discipline
discovery bay in huddersfield is run by
barrington douglas whose mum taught him
everything there is to know about
caribbean cuisine
my passion for cooking started off at
home with my mum cooking there was five
boys no girls
and there was one day my mum says right
i want somebody to learn how to cook so
she put me to one side
and that's where it started gentle giant
barrington is keen to pass on his
knowledge he mentors local young people
teaching them how to cook
it treats me like one of his sons he's
like a dead to me and i do anything for
him
discovery based starter is jerk chicken
caesar salad barrington fries chicken
marinaded and jerk seasoning made with
scotch bonnet peppers garlic black
pepper cinnamon nutmeg thyme and
allspice he dresses mixed leaf salad in
caesar sauce
[Music]
now barry what's so special about this
recipe what is it is the seasoning on
the jerk chicken we do a lot of jerk
chicken in in the caribbean yes but this
is where i'm just trying to bring it to
a little bit of a european taste as well
with a caesar salad so would you say
your interpretation is more modern more
modern more modern so more dangerous
more dangerous accent
in terms of being in the middle of paris
it's like a little sort of communal
pocket of argentina yeah we are really
friendly and we are like a small family
yeah yeah we're going to dance and salsa
sometimes
yeah are you teaching him was he
teaching you no he's teaching
okay good four more excellent and how
old when you first started cooking um my
first time seven years old seven years
ago what was the first thing you took
one it was peak
north and south america are stuffed with
the most amazing ingredients here's one
of the most delicious
[Music]
canada in the northern tip of the
american continent is home to some of
the most delicious wildfowl in the world
[Music]
with christmas coming up and goose one
of my favorite festive foods i couldn't
be in a better place
quebec where almost a million wild snow
geese stop off once a year as they
migrate south
always been a big fan of british goose
however the snow goose is a canadian
ancestor and they say taste wise is in a
completely different league i can't wait
to try it
i'm in the town of monmoney where snow
goose is so famous it's like the local
mascot
there are thousands here so i'd like to
think they only have the best wild snow
goose on the local restaurant menus
[Music]
very light in color
that unfortunately was a bit of a
letdown i was expecting more of a sort
of richer gamier slightly livery flavor
that's the kind of goose you can get
anywhere certainly not worth coming all
the way to quebec for that's for sure
this goose has too much fat on it to be
a wild delicacy
so i want to grill the head chef
frederique to find out where it came
from how are you all right you yeah
rondi thank you happy to be here yeah
but then my goose arrived so that is
snow geese
no that's firemen geese that's farm
geese yeah why are you serving me farm
geese when you've got hundreds of
thousands of them in your front garden
because it's illegal illegal it's not
legal we eat at home
but we can serve at the restaurant we
can't serve the restaurants
but that's madness from a chef to chef
yeah wild yeah it's completely different
it's not the same flavor chalk and
cheese yeah
because the canadian authorities can't
monitor the health of wild snow geese
they don't allow restaurants like this
one to sell it
so the only way i can actually go and
eat a wild snow goose if i go and shoot
the bloody thing myself yeah
to maximise my chances of finding a wild
snow goose i headed out of town and
further up the st lawrence river
this vast waterway is 70 kilometers wide
and is prime feeding ground for
migrating birds
daniela chance has been hunting here
since he was a child
look at them all
there's loads of geeks incredible in the
area here about five hundred thousand
slogans half a million
half a million yeah my god all i want to
taste is one
that's all i want is one
arimo island in the middle of the river
is one of daniel's best hunting spots
we start at 5 a.m the next morning to
get into position before the snow geese
spot us
trudging our way across the riverbed as
soon as the tide goes out
the tide's gone out
and this mud is bloody deep though yeah
really bloody [ __ ]
my god
a few hours ago these hides below ground
were buried deep underwater
i've done some pretty crazy things in my
life in order to get food but i've never
done this i sat in the middle of a river
in a box holy crap
we sit under cover of darkness waiting
for the snow geese to fly in
so when we see them do we dive down do
we
it's really really important not to show
our faces because they're pretty smart
daniel mimics the call of the geese to
try and attract passing birds
says go
no
go
cheers
oh my god it's really with the troll
tear there
an hour later as the sun begins to burst
through the clouds the snow geese start
to fly in
and arrive on the riverbed in the
thousands
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i just wish one or two of them would
land near us
[Music]
but there must be one how many there
probably between ten and fifteen
thousand snoogies there
oh [ __ ]
snow geese have incredibly sharp sight
and a keen sense of danger which was
keeping them well away from us so we've
got fifteen thousand geese sat there and
five thousand sat there
and we're stuck here yeah who put the
box here
was it the fringe
what the [ __ ]
all i want is one
one
little
goose
[ __ ]
it's the distances these wild birds fly
that makes their meat lean and delicious
to eat but as they move around the river
they were proving too clever for us
you think it'd be a lot easier to catch
them but no they are not easy to cash
they are very very intelligent birds
plan b
if i wanted to taste this amazing
delicacy i had no option but to find
another hunting spot
[Music]
hey guys yes all the food's looking
fantastic you've got four more away now
please yeah yeah i think last time was a
four yes yes chef uh barry to make sure
the last table is as good as the first
table yes yes [ __ ] i wish you baron they
look fantastic
cynthia always starters out thank you
chef brilliant are you always this quick
yes i like do it yeah do you have rhythm
yes what's the first move he taught you
cynthia
show me down show me jesus no hold on
sure
later maybe you can show me a few moves
after the main course yeah cynthia get
ready i've got a size 15 feet
very light and not too filling so nice
for starter really lovely the chili
wasn't too strong just light and yeah
it's beautiful
josie how are you sir fine nice to see
you good to see you hello how are you
welcome to the effort thank you very
much thank you for inviting us all
congratulations watching your team yes
it's great it's great it's great i think
they they are smiling enjoying the time
yeah it's a very passionate pair they
work very well together
nice chemistry yeah real good chemistry
argentinians are a very proud nation
very proud i think they do whether they
play football
how do you feel if you lose tonight it's
like uh not going to work up right it's
gonna be that yeah that's right yes yes
i think this is the world cup for us
right everybody good to see you yeah
it's a pleasure to have you here
thank you thank you very much thank you
really nicely presented and tastes
fantastic really really pleased it was
really nice it was well dressed it was
fresh salad the chicken was cooked
really well
now good evening welcome good day
tonight
lovely thank you morris good day good to
see you how are you i'm very well too
how do you think barrington and sean do
i think they're doing really well
he's the kind of guy who can cope under
pressure how long have you known each
other uh over 15 years and what's so
special about discovery bay what is it
it's the heart and the soul that's gone
into the place and how much does tonight
mean to him and leaving here as a winner
that would mean
a lot to barrington and he's took a big
risk in his life to put money into the
business so um to him this will just put
iceland on a cake enjoy main courses i
look forward to seeing you after thank
you excellent thank you
all right empanadas santa maria uh
classic
a version of a cornish pasty ready
chicken chili and olives with a little
chili salad
banned with some eggs
that's delicious really good pastry's
nice and crispy
filling is absolutely delicious
nice beautiful executed and stunning
pastry okay discovery bay jerk chicken
caesar salad not what i expected to see
from a caribbean restaurant however this
guy is ambitious and incredibly
confident
chicken's really nice the more you eat
the chicken the more the intense flavor
the joke's teasing really really good
two stunning dishes absolutely neck and
neck personally if i had to choose one
i'd go for the empanada absolutely
delicious
if the diners don't like their starters
they don't pay the results are in right
uh barrington um out of 25. how well do
you think your caribbean chicken caesar
salad went down 50 50. interesting
ernesto empanadas 14.
okay jp
please
uh let's start off with uh
santa maria yeah
the number of customers are happy to pay
for your starters out of 25
is
23 out of 25. well done
that's amazing
well done that is a fantastic score for
the starters huh what do they like about
the most jb um they love the
combinations the feeling was very good
so they absolutely love it
okay barrington
the number of customers they're happy to
pay
for your jerk
caesar salad out of 25 is
it's 23 out of 25 1000
well done
well done
that is extraordinary
absolutely amazing feedback from the
season salad was what um did you love
the crouton do you think the chicken was
very tender
all of you have done fantastically well
23 out of 25 now
is where it really goes up a different
level really push the boat out yeah well
done great start clear down start up
make all right now both restaurants are
going to cook their main courses first
up discovery bay
at discovery bay in huddersfield
barrington's menu combines classic
carving recipes with european
ingredients
we've got the specials where i try to
fuse food together so we might use
pastas linguine rocket leaves
barrington's ambitious approach to
caribbean dining has been a hit with the
yorkshire locals it's lovely it's nice
to come into a restaurant and sit and
eat the food rather than going to like a
caribbean cafe the taste in the food
when he does it it's just like something
it's just like the mother's cooking it's
not better sorry
check on
thank you one rum park
barrington's main course is one of his
most popular dishes rum pork with sweet
potatoes
barrington starts by marinating pork
medallions with fresh thyme rosemary
black pepper
chopped garlic and dark rum
for the rum gravy heats up beef stock
and adds red green and yellow peppers
we've got the red yellow and green so we
have got the rasaman colours and the
colours of the caribbean islands as well
running through there
and what we've got here we've got the
old jamaica room
[Music]
daryl dew
next he griddles of pork medallions
and sliced sweet potato
he adds the pork medallions to the rum
gravy and finishes with cream
he serves with steamed vegetables
smells absolutely beautiful
awake here and please
pork with sweet potatoes served
so barrington
the secret behind this main course is
what it's a stock basically it's a
reduction of the stock um
a nice little kicker
what's the heat at the back that's a
little bit of scotch bonnet pepper in
there
okay
when you're standing in front of that
grill that's a very difficult thing to
operate in battersea
how do you get the temperature of the
steaks cooked perfectly what is this we
need to move the grill to that
high you have slow middle depends how
good the people want so you're not
touching the stakes
it's all with this yes your tongue is
the same when you touch your hands yep
when you touch here
yep right yeah yep
here's what santa maria are cooking
tonight
at santa maria del sur in south london
they use only the finest argentinian
beef i think argentinian beef is one of
the best in the world because we have so
much nice grass nice weather the way the
cows eat the way they live makes the
beef that tasty and tender
you can really taste the difference to
any other beef that you can eat this is
really excellent table five
santa maria's signature dish tonight is
argentinian ribeye steak with
chimichurri sauce
[Music]
for the chimichurri ernesto chops
parsley and garlic and blends with olive
oil
something really very nice
he adds bay leaves ground sweet red
pepper oregano sea salt and mixes
he stirs in warm water to infuse the
flavors
he finishes with white wine vinegar and
chopped red onion the chimichurri is the
real tasty sauce from argentina
ernesto char grills an argentinian
ribeye steak and seasons with olive oil
and sea salt
not too much
he serves with a rocket and sugar snap
salad dresses with toasted sesame and
sunflower seeds chimichurri sauce on the
side
and garnish the steak with a slice of
roasted red pepper now it's done
argentinian ribeye steak with
chimichurri sauce served
health and safety have banned me from
having an open fire in my kitchen so
i've had a special grill installed why
did you choose a ribeye over a fillet or
a sirloin because the fat has special
flavor
and what makes argentinian beef so
special what is it about the wettest
conditions and is it one of the best
meats in the world i think it's the best
do you think it's the best yes why not
you think it's better than scottish
yes
you may be better than as a football but
i don't know about the steaks however
we'll find out later yes yeah yeah
bloody smoke in here what we've done to
my kitchen it's always like this yes
what's the material time all the time
all the time honestly it's like you're
sending smoke signals huh is that trying
to put barrington off what's all that
about no yes
that's right unless so you happy with
them yes they look fantastic yeah away
please tell me one let's go now cynthia
you have six now three minutes the next
table thank you right now back to canada
i'm in quebec in north america on the
hunt for one of the most delicious birds
in the world
the snow goose
almost a million descend on the salons
river for a few weeks each year so far
i've had little luck shooting one
[Music]
a new day and daniel takes me to a new
hunting spot this time thankfully on dry
land
so why don't you bring me here yesterday
in a nice little sort of bunker than
being sat in the middle of a river
sometimes it's better there sometimes
it's better here it feels right here
yeah well we're uh we're well placed and
it's getting nice and white over there
isn't it yeah they began to be maybe two
or three thousand now
so when they fly over i can shoot any
one if you want to eat it yeah the gray
ones are much more better because they
are more tender because they're the
youngsters exactly yeah we've just made
it 10 times more difficult so it's not
just about shooting a snowgies no he's
looking for the grey ones exactly
young grey geese have migrated fewer
miles than older birds so the meat is
more tender
it isn't long before we get our first
chance
chew
miss that but not bad order will come
they're looking good these ones here
ready
aiming for a straight goose on the move
is the best way to ensure we hit just
one with a clean shot
and finally one came our way oh sure got
him
[Music]
yes yeah
[ __ ]
i've got my goose but was it the right
age and the very best to eat brilliant
ah
perfect young one for one young wife my
god look at that baby there well
and how young is that is that the
perfect age it's a it's a
fresh fresh snow goose of the of the
year
honestly i'm so pleased to get one
that's brilliantly we got one finally ah
we got excellent well done
beautiful woods huh
before i can cook snow goose for the
first time daniel shows me how to
de-breast the bird
now to get the breasts off you just have
to pull like that
and see everything is coming it's
incredible
and look how thin that fat is
there's hardly any fat on there a lot
darker than i expected yeah it's like a
red brown meat yeah like venison
and the breasts are quite thick as well
i thought i thought they'd be thinner
close to an inch yup it's incredible
christmas is fast approaching and goose
is one of my favorite birds to cook
and i've got a recipe that'll bring out
this wild meat's rich gamey flavor
perfectly this is the first for me a
delicious lean snow goose breast with a
rich red wine tomato sauce finished with
sweet potatoes onions and garlic
first slice the potatoes and par boil
with olive oil and a bit of salt pan on
for the goose
season the snow goose and fry it with
rosemary garlic and butter once it's
beautifully colored take it out of the
pan now to go with a snow goose under a
really nice red wine tomato sauce fry
some chopped onions and garlic
nice
then add red wine to the pan
really important to reduce the red wine
down to a syrup otherwise you've got
that sort of raw alcohol flavor in the
sauce
add chopped tomatoes and chicken stock
and then the snow goose goes back to
finish cooking with some butter
the butter gives the sauce a nice glaze
the snow goose is rich so the soda
potatoes will be very simple
now the secret to get our skin really
nice and crispy
they're fried with some chopped onion
garlic thyme and butter
slice the snow goose nice and thinly
now put the sauce on top
this is definitely one of the most
exciting ingredients i've ever cooked i
can't wait to try it
that is so delicate yeah incredibly
tender
it's really delicious yeah it's really
great that's given me a completely
different
taste and experience than i ever could
imagine it smells delicious it tastes
delicious and also it's very healthy
yeah because it's no fat no fat i'm
really really really happy with that and
what an amazing discovery and thank you
i just need one more favor i need to
redirect the snow goose via scotland
so i don't have to travel so far next
time that is incredible but that's
really great yeah really good
okay good ernesto cynthia last table now
yeah yeah yeah four and 16 away yeah
they look great they smell delicious
now your sauce has started to get darker
now is that because you changed the
recipe or are you just over a duty
quite a bit yeah yeah
every plate got to look the same yeah
ernesto thank you
well done thank you pretty good thank
you right well done yeah clear down yeah
drink some water job well done thank you
jeff
i really enjoyed the pork really nice
really well cooked and the sauce is
gorgeous flavors are amazing um very
moorish very like you want to lick your
plate literally the sauce was incredible
steak was delicious very tender um i
like the sauce that was with the
chimichurri i hadn't tried that before
so it was nice to try that the steak was
lush i don't usually like rare steak to
be honest with you but um changed my
views probably
right
argentinian beef santa maria briefly
cooked lovely colour
sauce a little bit of grilled pepper on
there
that
is cooked perfectly it's incredibly
juicy
mmm and packed full of flavor salad
unfortunately a little bit bland
slightly boring
it's not very nice eating raw onion with
the most amazing steak however ernesto
really knows your stuff that
is perfection
discovery bay fillets of pork
with a creamy rum sauce and vegetables
sat on a bed of sweet potato
looks
a little bit more complex
sauce is delicious pork is delicious as
well
and i'm so glad you put that rum in
there because that really sort of wakes
up that richness
um tough choice this one
if i was the diner
and i had to choose between them both
i'd have to say
i'd go for the steak
so the results are in right barrington
out of 50. give us a number 45. 45 out
of 50. yeah
46.46
one more and discovery bank okay good jb
please results okay let's start off with
discovery bay
so the number of customers that are
happy to pay for your pork dish is
wow
[Music]
30 out of 50. huh very good score
the
the customers they loved it what did
they say yeah they loved the flavors and
the things was very well seasoned and
the 20 customers that didn't pay um
overcooked slightly too dry i tasted the
pork i thought it was delicious yeah
yeah that's still a very respectful
score yeah yeah okay right santa maria
the number of customers that happy to
pay
for your steak out of 50 is
it's 38 out of 50. congratulations well
done
well done well done well done
congratulations
um so what do they like first about the
steak um they found the steak very
tender very tender twelve that aren't
paying for it what do they say um some
of them find it overcooked overcooked
yeah
okay well done 38 out of 50. fantastic
all four we now cooking 25 portions of
the dessert so it is still incredibly
close yeah you can bring this back yeah
and you can lose it if you're not
careful clear down and get ready for
desserts yeah let's go
continuing tonight's america's theme ian
wright is planning to score with
caribbean jerk chicken in the recipe
challenge he was a hero on the pitch but
is he a jerk in the kitchen are you
ready i am ready um yes i'm ready he's
doing a traditional jerk chicken and i'm
doing my own version
now is this mom's recipe yes you know so
i grew up with and what's the secret
behind it why do you love it so much i
like the spiciness of it we're going to
do it in the oven here it's normally
done in a drum side of a road i want to
score this i'm very very nervous about
this knife is that how you score it uh
no i'm just taking my bone off ah well
i'm not going to bother with that no um
and what other kind of dishes do mom
used to cook obviously the main one was
the rice and freezing chicken
dumplings yams green bananas and
normally my mum would have this seasoned
overnight i'm gonna use cinnamon chili
allspice nutmeg cloves salt and pepper
almost like a bit of a dry rub first you
seem like you've got so much more stuff
on your stuff than me man
jesus i want more stuff on mine but
don't copy me i'm not copying you but i
just don't like the way you're kind of
like moving ahead and it looks like
you're you're your season looks good
she's not
be cut yourself
oh jesus i'm coming here bloody hell
thank you
ian
this is positive news for me because it
makes me feel like i'm gonna win the
challenge you know what i think what
you've done is you've just got me
talking so much yeah that you know i
mean i'm using the knife trying to copy
you use the knife like all smooth and
cool that's like me trying to copy you
taking penalties thing is you're either
cool or you're not i know because a lot
for the family um not really no the most
i do now is spaghetti bolognese i never
had a lot of pasta when i was a kid it
was very much um hard food jamaican food
most of the time
all right keep your fingers well away
from that that's it yeah good right what
i'm doing is that out i'm this is to go
into my secret ian right jerk chicken
sauce um so i've got garlic in there
spring onions scotch bonnet peppers
thyme black pepper everything i've got
everything in there
and uh this is what's gonna give it the
spiciness the beautifulness now you're
presenting a new chat show on channel
five yes michael parkerson said it was
the worst ever chat show on tv who said
that michael parker michael parkerson
you know he slaughters everyone yes what
he's got to do is he just got you know i
mean just go gracefully he should be
doing stepping baths now and then
motorized
motorized weenie things standard lives
stair lifts that's what you should be
doing what i'm doing now is i'm putting
my sauce over the chicken so it can get
in there i'm really liking it at the
moment hopefully the taster will like it
roasting off the chicken
and then just finishing that with a
couple of tablespoons of liam perrin
now that darkens the chicken makes a
little bit more spicy got a really good
color on there and then into a tray now
you spit your mind a lot like i do yes
well you've got to off the chest and
deal with it and then sometimes you say
stuff and you just have to
just have to try and get the poo back in
the office that's all you got to do
come on chicken do it for me now your
amanda likes to get on the top or the
bottom which one's going to give me the
most heat because you fried yours a lot
longer i'll go top then right now they
both go in the oven there for 20 minutes
we come back and the blind tasters will
taste them i predict scotland won
england neal
right welcome back to the f word now
time for the results of the recipe
challenge you're excited
it smells delicious thank you yes i'm
really pleased with it
all right i'm ready to go moment of
truth
get your jerk chicken on there my son
will it be all right on the night off
you go good luck thanks a lot gordon ah
she's gonna need it
oh this one's very different it's not
quite as crispy on the outside it's
sweeter yeah it's much sweeter i'm quite
nervous yeah i'm very nervous i hate the
results right jb
so the winner for today is come on
england scotland scotland
[Applause]
is one of my best they really love both
okay very cool and and it was snacky to
sweet what can you do you're [ __ ] and
you know you are you love me i know you
one meal to ramsey
time for the brigade's final challenge
dessert a perfect combination of peaches
a very popular fruit in argentina and
rum the caribbean's favorite drink
roasted peaches flambaid in rum sweet
fruity and totally indulgent peaches
slice
hot pan cast the sugar caramelize
peaches in and then just gently toss
them in the caramel
butter
and now for the rum
flambe
woof
[Music]
lime cream
180 mil of double cream
whisk
icing sugar
lime zest
[Music]
shortbread on the plate
and then start layering
icing sugar
roasted peaches with rum and lime cream
done
now barrington
yeah ernesto yeah this is unbelievably
close okay yeah it can be won and lost
on dessert yeah keep it going yeah every
plate counts very nice barrington they
look fantastic
if that caramel's too strong ernesto no
one's gonna be able to eat it yeah be
very very careful yeah yes a nice light
blonde caramel yeah yeah good and
remember ernesto burlington it's a
competition yes yes yep yeah may the
best chef win
if discovery may win tonight will be a
proud achievement for barrington and his
team
all this time and effort that i put in
there it would just put the icing on the
cake and i just think we're doing
something right we're definitely doing
something right
and for santa maria del sur victory will
transform a restaurant already famous in
south london into a national success
story
winning this award will mean i think
that's it i mean it's nothing
higher
last two tables ernesto yes watch that
caramel yes that camel has to be
absolutely delicious yeah chef sean if
you're not happy with the camera you
don't send it yes yes and the camera's
not cooked out properly they all stick
together so can't be too thick go tilt
the pan there you go good man
that's better ernesto thank you chef
yeah much better it's not a race guys
huh ernesto oh the last table going out
as good as the first table yeah really
important yeah jeff
it was absolutely amazing the peaches
were very sweet
they really complemented the biscuit
base as well
the cream was great and it counteracted
the sweet taste of the toffee that's
really nice
right roasted peaches with lime cream
that's delicious
a nice
taste of rum on the peach
and the secret there is they've got this
really nice caramel they haven't
overcooked the peaches but this really
nice rum flavour comes through with the
lime cream
delicious really really good indeed
now discovery bay again nice color on
the caramel
peaches cooked nicely
caramel just a little bit undercooked
kneaded 30 more seconds in the
pan hmm
those peaches that barrington cooked are
absolutely delicious the results are in
and it's time to find out who our winner
is tonight right barrington
very calm composed
i'm doing those amazing peaches yeah
no dancing no smiling no okay
jb please
thank you
okay discovery bay
the
number of customers that happened to pay
for the dessert out of 25 yeah yes
congratulations 22 out of 25. that's
amazing
that is amazing
very good score indeed happy yes
really good yes sir
okay good santa maria
if you get 15 or more you have one
let's see the number of customers that
are happy to pay for dessert
out of 25 is
is 25 out of 25 well done
that is amazing
fantastic that means 86
out of
right at the top of the leaderboard
congratulations fantastic news